am mittwochmittag werden letzte reste
von eis und schnee vor dem hangar 7 am
salzburger flughafen entfernt damit die
saab 105 golden tiger problemlos ihre
parkposition einnehmen kann
für die piloten des überstellung des
flugs nach salzburg ein emotionaler
moment nach so vielen jahren wirklich
diesen überstellung flug mit dabei zu
sein und vor allem die saab 105 hat mich
jahrzehntelang begleitet es ist ein
unglaubliches ereignis hier heute gesagt
auf einladung der flying bulls salzburg
zu fliegen
das flugzeug mit großer vergangenheit
soll im hangar-7 für mindestens zwei
monate der öffentlichkeit zur
besichtigung zugänglich gemacht werden
wie das allerdings im österreichweiten
lockdown zurzeit möglich sein soll und
mehr unterliegen natürlich genauso denn
womit bestimmungen für alle anderen
wollen wir sein natürlicher weise immer
optimisten wir hoffen dass sie
irgendwann auch die möglichkeit wieder
besteht dass die leute auch bei uns in
den handel wieder rein können und auf
das warten und hoffen und dann werde man
sehen wie weit das ausgedehnt oder
geöffnet wird und wir werden sehen noch
einmal also einen blick auf die flug
legende aus nächster nähe werfen zu
können könnte im hangar-7 wirklichkeit
werden deshalb 105 ist einfach ein stück
des weges jedes einsatzpiloten der in
österreich an jet fliegt jeder tragen
pilot und auch jeder heutige eurofighter
pilot ist auf 105 geflogen und das ist
einfach ein besonderer schritt in der
ausbildung und bei den flying bulls
fühlt man sich ob der anwesenheit der
golden tiger sichtlich geehrt kam ich
als ehre bezeichnet zu einem flugzeug
für uns so zu haben zum ausstellen
für die leute ist jedenfalls sehr sehr
interessantes projekt